So now, we've got a simple mechanical solution and we've written out a pseudo
code. So now, we're ready to start coding but we should think carefully about
how to do that. So now, the question is what should we do first? The choices
are, we should write the days between dates procedure that solves the whole
problem. We should write a next day procedure that takes a current date given as
a year, month, and a day, and returns the next day. But only deal with simple
cases. Let's assume all months have the same number of days. We should write an
isLeapYyear procedure that takes a year and returns true or false, determining
if that year is a leap year. Or we should write a daysInMonth procedure that
takes a month and returns the number of days in that month. This is quite a
subjective question. You could certainly make an argument for at least two of
these answers. But I want you to try and figure out which one is the best
answer.